انها قصه غريبه تاتينا من عندي سفح
الاهرام في مصر سائحه اجنبيه تشعل الجدل
ثم الذي حصل
سائحه اجنبيه حاولت التعري وخلع ملابسها
امام ابو الهول والهدف كان التقاطه سيلفي
وصور تذكاريه خلال زيارتها لاشهر المواقع
الاثريه في مصر
السلطات بطبيعه الحال مناعه السائحه فيما
اوضحت ازاله السياحه المصريه ان التعري في
مكان عام يعد مخالفا للقوانين والعادات
والتقاليد المصريه وبحسب الوزاره لاحظ احد
افراد الامن قيام السائحه بالتجرد من
ملابسها وكانت تريد التقاط بعض الصور لها
امام ثاني ابو الهول وعندها قام افراد
الامن بتوجعها لارتداء ملابسها
ان التجرد من الملابس مخالفا للقوانين
وفي النهايه تم السماحه لهذه السائحه
باستكمال زيارتها بدون اي معوقات ولو انها
لم تحصل على الصوره التي كانت تتمنى
الحصول عليها
السلطات انها شدت جميع الزوار التزموا
بالضوابط والقوانين لان سمعه مصر السياحيه
تعتمد على ذلك